why were you in tuskegee alabama
man all right i was um
opening up for the homecoming for boozy
oh
yeah what year was this 20
[Music]
like
14 15 i think so you were like
young yeah i was i was probably like
like 21 20.
so you were opening up for boozy in
alabama yeah for they homecoming touch
it my uh my folks i went to uh shao
richard he was
going to school out there and he brought
us out there because he was like on the
little uh i guess what's that [ __ ]
called
fresh fresh by the way that's fresh out
of prison boozy yeah that was i'm coming
home booty that was i'm crazy boo see
that one
so yeah he was on the committee type
[ __ ] and he got us like to open up on so
we're doing shows out there
like day parties out there
was it fun homies was trapping out there
you told me it was a vibe bro it was
like one of the best experiences i've
had like getting
like three in the morning drunk and go
to the gas station you can get chicken
and mac and cheese and yeah it's great i
love the south yeah
you know as a west coast guy i was
living in florida
i was living in tampa when boozy got out
of prison
and i didn't fully grasp i i'd always
known like i guess i had like a better
grasp
more than most people on the west coast
i didn't really fully understand like
the hole that boozy has in certain parts
of this country yeah that was that's my
favorite rapper like wow you guys got a
record together but in terms of like you
seeing it in alabama did that kind of
where you like [ __ ] this is different
let me tell you what happened i was we
was the people that was supposed to go
up right before him right
so boosie was that's when booty was just
i'm busy like he like i want to go on
stage early we didn't get to perform oh
[ __ ] yeah so he was out there really for
another night like just hanging out got
did you get a flick with him at least
nothing he i listen he was walking like
when they told us to get off stage
boosie don't perform like we was walking
on stage actually and they like you know
kind of past
and i said something to them i'm like
man they're not trying to listen to the
[ __ ] you said you're going on early
i guess here's my favorite rapper
he just walked past me did you tell him
this story when you ended up working
with him he'll not because now i
understand the game and i ain't gonna
lie to you like i can't tell you that
like if he was coming to get his back
and get on that's what he was doing you
feel me yeah and that's what i'd be on
sometimes too
for me so i
i probably took it hard back then but
like
when i seen him i was just so happy it
was like a full like full circle type
[ __ ]
he's one of the few um
artists that
when you meet him just doesn't
disappoint your expectations right
that's what man that's crazy that's what
we were saying too like
he came in he brought the vibe
and he tugged it with us you know what
i'm saying and
he a real hood [ __ ] like hey and back
then though he was doing [ __ ] to where
he was going to clubs
he was performing like
two songs and then he'll perform shut it
off because he knew they like
started fighting yeah
and he did that yeah he felt me and i
was like what bro when he first got out
of prison he was getting stupid money
what dude he was getting like a hundred
and twenty five thousand decisions
oh my god
set it off they start fighting i'm like
oh
yeah sometimes you will like meet people
we grew up loving and then they'll like
disappoint us you know yeah
or you'll be like oh this is obviously
who i was watching on music videos and
in the magazines when i was growing up
yeah and i think i was so understanding
too always like of [ __ ] like
rappers like artists like
how they are like you know what i'm
saying like adapting to like lifestyles
like that and i was like i always wanted
to be that person
you feel me like i had dreams of like
walking somewhere like and ignoring all
these people that love me like you know
what i'm saying like it's not i don't do
it but like you feel me it's happening
sometimes you get your [ __ ] off it's
rapper [ __ ] yeah so yeah like i said
like when i seen him again i'm like damn
[ __ ] all that other [ __ ] man